vaccine passports are coming
someday soon you may need to prove your
covert status
to go to the pub travel abroad or even
go to work governments hope
these passes could be key to
kick-starting the economy
and restoring basic freedoms but could
this come
at a cost to individuals
the weekend is underway in tel aviv in
israel
restaurants here only recently reopened
from lockdown
but covert 19 feels like a distant
memory
the reason the green pass an app
that lets you prove you've had the jab
[Music]
you know as a chef it's it's made me
happy like
it's a huge joy we feel like uh we see
colors again israel is winning the
global vaccination race
most over 40s are now fully vaccinated
and if you've had both jabs the green
pass opens doors
giving you access to restaurants hotels
and gyms i saw a lot of young people
that it was for them the incentive to do
it
they wanted to come back to life
actually more than a paper
green paper just come back to life
the green pass might be new but vaccine
passports are not
travellers to regions with yellow fever
already need to carry a vaccination
certificate
and children attending public school in
america must be vaccinated for several
diseases
but governments are now paying keen
attention to schemes like the green pass
eu leaders have agreed to develop a
covet 19 vaccine digital
vaccine passports that could to see if
they could be
key to lifting lockdowns
but how well would they actually work
vaccine passports might not be that
effective for two reasons
first although vaccines prevent serious
illness
it's not yet clear how effectively they
stop the spread
of covert 19 particularly for new
variants
so vaccinated people could potentially
still pass covid
on to others second
vaccine passports are only useful for a
very limited window domestically
they're not very useful early on because
there's not many people who benefit
and they're not very useful late on
either because vaccines work in two ways
they work by protecting you by priming
your immune system
so that if you meet an infection you're
ready to fight it off
but they also work by making sure that
you mostly won't meet infection because
other people around you are vaccinated
too
if as in israel most people have been
vaccinated
then the chances of meeting an infected
person are low
so a vaccine passport adds little
additional protection
however in places that are taking longer
to vaccinate
like the eu these passports could be
useful for much
longer to help reopen the economy
[Music]
but could cobid passports create
inequality
[Music]
most countries are vaccinating old
people first
and some think vaccine passports could
risk creating a two-tiered society
where vaccinated seniors can resume
normal life
while the young are stuck inside waiting
for the jab
so the vaccine passport is quite a
temporary thing that maybe governments
just use as one tool as they exit
lockdown
if the government is quick and fair and
transparent about it i think that sort
of issue of unfairness
will seem reasonable it's unfairness for
a bigger fairness
in israel relatively few under-16s have
had the jab
so they can't go inside restaurants
but most seem willing to make this small
sacrifice
or not eat out at all if it's too cold
we got yesterday uh like seven
uh guests that one of them was like 16
years old
and it was pretty cold outside and they
asked they understand they said with the
coat and
all good you know we we have to protect
each other
a bigger sticking point is jobs
some businesses from care homes to
plumbing firms
have already said they'll require proof
of vaccination from new employees
we're just going to make it a
requirement it's going to be important
for us to protect customers and our
members of staff
this could make it harder for the
unvaccinated to find
work it's already the case that we
require people in certain sensitive jobs
for example in the armed forces or
working in certain healthcare settings
to have all their vaccines
so i don't think it would be
unreasonable or surprising that covid
got added to that list
what we would worry about is if this
became just a requirement to do any job
[Music]
this would be especially problematic as
some groups are much less likely to have
had the jab than others
across 39 states in america the
vaccination
rate among white people is over twice as
high as the rate for hispanic people
and nearly twice as high as the rate for
black people
this may be because black americans are
on average
younger than whites meaning they're
further back in the vaccine queue
they're also less likely to trust the
vaccine because of a long history of
misuse of health data
and bad vaccine programs where i think
you might worry about
entrenching inequality in the longer
term is if this sort of scheme
becomes a power grab and ends up being
something that allows health data to be
used
to govern access to public spaces and to
work places
but this could be avoided if cobit
passports are a temporary measure
and restricted to certain key
professions
there are also concerns over freedom of
choice
back in tel aviv you need proof of
vaccination to access
many aspects of normal life and some
people
like mikhail feel they had no choice but
to have the jab
i'm a healthy 41 year old woman i don't
think
i needed the vaccination against kovid
the only reason
why i got the vaccination was not for
health reasons
it was just because if you're not
vaccinated you can't go places you can't
go
to the gym you can leave the country
if covered passports were to be rolled
out many people could face stark choices
like these
in return for short-term freedoms rather
than feeling
forced to have the jab people should
have access to information that allows
them to make an informed decision
the economist has built an interactive
covert 19 risk estimator
to help with these decisions you can try
it yourself
at the link above perhaps
one of the biggest concerns around
covert passports is
data privacy a vaccine passport is based
on
sensitive health data and some worry
this could open the door to allowing
governments to snoop on their citizens
take singapore the government promised
data gathered by its contact tracing app
would only be used to stop the spread of
covert 19
but in january they admitted the data
had been shared with the police to fight
crime
do we really want to live in a world
where government agencies
are able just to see where you were you
could imagine all sorts of bad
uses for that data singapore's
government said the data sharing was a
mistake
and developers working on vaccine
passports are confident they will be
designed in a way that will share
minimal personal data
one area where development is racing
ahead is international travel
there are already several digital health
apps in development
that allow people to prove their covert
free and in time
vaccinated if you want people to be able
to travel between countries that are
incredibly different stages in their
journey towards conquering coverage
you might decide that you only allow
people to cross borders if you could
think of them as covert safe
countries like israel america and
britain may be racing towards herd
immunity
but large parts of africa may not get
the jab for at least the next two years
a covered passport would let vaccinated
people cross borders and provide a
welcome boost to crippled economies
countries like greece have already said
they will welcome
vaccinated brits this summer but
tourists shouldn't pack their bags
just yet a third wave of the virus is
sweeping much of europe
and vaccinated holidaymakers could still
cause local
outbreaks of disease any tourists who
arrive
even if they're vaccinated they're going
to be a reason that unvaccinated greeks
are coming out and mingling and that
will increase the number of cases it's
really a trade-off it's a trade-off here
between
getting the economy going again and
increasing the number of cases
governments need to be really really
transparent about that to explain to
people
this is the hard choice that's in front
of us what do you think what are the
trade-offs that you would find
acceptable
israel's economy is predicted to grow by
up to 7.5 percent this year if the
vaccination program continues at its
current rate but it remains to be seen
how long
this green pass effect will last
vaccine passports are just one of many
useful tools to help
restart the global economy and although
developers already overcoming concerns
about privacy and security
their domestic success will depend on
how well the vaccines themselves prevent
transmission of covert 19
and how quickly countries can reach herd
immunity
i'm helen joyce deputy foreign editor at
the economist
you can read my reporting on vaccine
passports by clicking on the link
opposite thank you for watching and
don't forget to subscribe
you